ce smartphone ce qu'il faut vraiment
retenir dessus c'est vraiment c'est un
appareil qui est complètement dédié est
optimisé pour le multimédia deux points
vraiment vraiment vraiment fort au
risque de nous répéter c'est son écran
bravia oled qui est magnifique
deuxième point extrêmement fort c
[Musique]
aujourd'hui je vous parle a c'est mieux
que les lumières allumées et on va
changer la lumière du fonds ah voilà
c'est plus intime c'est mieux
aujourd'hui je vous parle d'un
smartphone qui en réalité n'est pas un
smartphone c'est une télé de poche
c'est un appareil multimédia de poche et
c'est aussi un appareil photo de poche
et ça c'est cool c'est le sony xperia il
est 3 je vous en ai déjà parlé quelques
fois du xè de croix est gelée enfin ici
au studio en test alors je les ai testés
s'est passé pas mal de temps dessus
et franchement je trouve que c'est un
appareil qui est très atypique parce que
on a beaucoup de smartphones avec des
écrans ou la donne a dû aux lettres
d'une super amoled du havre il a pas mal
de choses
là on a un écran qui est vraiment
extrêmement bien maîtrisé la partie
solide
si vous voulez et ce qu'il faut
comprendre et pourquoi est ce que sony
extrêmement fort avec cet appareil c'est
parce que sony ait maîtrise énormément
de technologie il faut savoir que les
capteurs sony équipe énormément de
produits du marché pardonner
inconsciente est comme ça d' enquête à
75 80 % du marché
je pense qu'on est à peu près là dessus
en terme de smartphone vous trouvez des
capteurs sony les leaks dans walk ou
beaucoup beaucoup de smartphones
pourquoi parce qu il les maîtrise
vraiment bien et que le rendu est top
alors après il ya différentes gammes
dans les i mx on va penser d'un côté un
peu trop technique mais toujours est il
que là dessus ils vous ont mis des
appareils qui sont juste à incroyable au
niveau de la photo
pourtant vous avez un seul objectif à
l'arrière à l'avant c'est la même chose
mais ça marche super bien donc c'est un
vrai bel appareil photo je voulais
taille dans quelques instants et autre
point qui est vraiment énorme ici mais
là dessus c'est l'écran j'aime beaucoup
cette marque solide je trouve qu'elle a
vraiment des produits qui sont up dont
beaucoup d'univers alors alliée à la
console est la playstation qui est un
carton monumental que ce soit au niveau
de l'audio au niveau de l'audio moi
j'utilise ailleurs 1 75 euro 6 qui
marche très bien ce moniteur de studio
et au niveau du smartphone on sait pas
pourquoi sony était franchement à la
bourde autant il y avait des produits de
qualité autant le design était pas du
tout du tout du tout du tout actuel avec
le z2 en début d'année sont déjà mis à
jour et avec le guide 3 franchement ils
ont un produit qui est très beau très
abouti et je trouve vraiment bien alors
déjà au niveau du design
si ajusta reproche à lui faire par
rapport à ce qui se fait en tout cas en
cette fin d'année c'est ce capteur à
l'arrière capteur d'empreintes digitales
on en a aujourd'hui qui sont sous
l'écran sautez pas mal
intégrée de l'écouter c'est un
smartphone qui est sorti au mois de
septembre bon je pense que peut-être
pour l'année prochaine on va trouver en
tout cas ce genre de choses si je
continue à tout petit peu dans leurs
proches et puis après j'arrête parce que
je trouve que c'est vraiment très bon
smartphone je trouve qu'il ya une vraie
confusion entre les deux c'est à dire
que moi quand je le prends comme ça je
positionnement doit
j'appuie suis dit que ça marche pas et
en empreintes digitales parce qu'en fin
de compte je pose mon doigt sur
l'appareil photo et ça je les fais plein
de fois et c'est vraiment le truc qui
m'a posé pendant deux ans que ça mais
ils marchent pas il marche pas je tape
mon code ta peau me rendre compte qu'en
fin de compte il faut aller bas ce qui
fait que lorsque vous le prenez dans
votre main de façon un peu classique
voyez je cale au creux de ma main ici je
tiens comme ça et bien la position
normale du capteur c'est celle de
l'appareil photo donc là je pense qu'il
ya un petit une petite erreur qui a été
fait ça aurait été plus logique de
positionner le capteur ici pour
déverrouiller et des portes un appareil
photo alors de mettre en haut avec le
flash à coûtera je sais par brassage
trouve que c'est en tout cas prendre
regrets après une fois qu'on a pris
l'habitude ça va je l'éteins japy dessus
ça marche très bien ça déverrouille très
rapidement voilà ça c'était la petite
aparté après au point de vue design je
trouve qu'il est vraiment super bien
réussi avec des bords arrondis indo
pareil fait vraiment son effet c'est
vraiment un smartphone très très classe
il ya un vrai beau boulot qui était fait
là dessus de la part sony c'est vraiment
un très très très bel appareil
nous avons plus de corning gorilla glass
5 ce qui ne gâche absolument rien point
de vue petite fonctionnalité vous le
voyez depuis tout à l'heure lorsque
j'appuie sur le côté eh bien ça va me
déclencher les raccourcis alors c'est
une option que je trouve vraiment
vraiment vraiment bien et très pratique
lorsque vous tenez votre smartphone
double tape ça vous ouvre ici les
applications que vous utilisez le plus
ça c'est pas vous qui décidez c'est
l'intelligence artificielle ça s'est
vraiment bien en plus vous faites un
ptit slide s'avoue ferme où ça vous fait
un retour en arrière
typiquement mais sur le ps store up qui
slide safer enfin ça c'est vraiment
pratique
maintenant ce problème c'est lorsque
vous le tenez comme ça eh ben ça a
toujours tendance un petit peu à
s'ouvrir voilà c'est un petit peu un
petit peu le souci vous l'avez vu depuis
tout à l'heure
après bon voilà ça se pense qu'il ya une
habitude de prise en main sur ce
smartphone il faut pas le tenir là voilà
après voyez c'est un petit peu sur tout
le côté bon voilà ça c'est un petit peu
un petit peu aussi un petit point à un
point de regrets à côté de ça il est
vraiment faim il fait 193 g
il ya un très très beau design l'écran
est complètement ouf c'est un écran 6
pouces bravia oled format 18/9 cdu qhd
plus de 1880 par 1447 un écran hd
r un écran qui est vraiment vraiment
vraiment magnifique ce qui est pop
là-dessus si vous voulez si vous avez
des noirs qui sont très profonds des
couleurs qui sont très très vives
vous avez une belle clarté de la netteté
vous avez un angle de vision plus qui
est complètement optimisé
vous mettez tous les côtés ça marche
bien il ya un upscale qui a été fait
pour vraiment adapté les vidéos sur du
netflix du youtube à la qualité de cet
appareil
ça marche vraiment très très bien c'est
vrai que c'est hyper hyper hyper hyper
bluffant alors là c'est un tout qui est
très compliqué montre en vidéo mais j'ai
la vibration qui est activée ce qui fait
que je sens complètement la vibration en
fonction du rythme de la musique
moi j'ai toujours appelé dubitatif je
trouve que la techno et bien c'est bien
de la m notamment pour du jeu vidéo
mais quand vous regardez un film et vous
tenez à la main au téléphone n'arrête
pas de vibrer il ya un côté un petit peu
un petit peu dérangeant après à côté de
ça l'audio et du tout
voyez vous avez ici là la vibration
dynamique on peut la baie si on peut la
régler ce bonbon les ponts budget là de
la subir par contre vous avez l'audio
là-dessus complètement ouf vous avez des
hauts parleurs stéréo on a vraiment de
sensation d'immersion c'est vraiment
génial
le sont très claires les méprise au
dessus de la part de sony
donc ça c'est vraiment bien pour le
multimédia l'écran au top
le son est génial les vibrations vous
aimez vous n'aimez pas vous aimez pas à
vous désactivez ça rajoute à l'immersion
il ya un vrai beau boulot là dessus a
été fait de la part de solides
donc pour moi ce xperia x3 c'est
vraiment un appareil qui est destiné au
multimédia
c'est pour ça que je vous dis que c'est
une télé poche c'est un mini bravia oled
2 6 pouces qui marche super bien une
vraie belle qualité c'est vraiment hyper
hyper hyper après ça et je vous dis là
où on va encore plus loin d'un côté
multimédia
c'est avec ces vibrations c'est avec de
l'audio de très bonne qualité et ça vous
allez voir c'est cool
maintenant je vais vous emmener voir
directement du côté du jeu vidéo mais
qui dit jeu vidéo dit aussi performances
vous avez un snapdragon 845 qui couplé à
4 gigas de ram et vous avez un score sur
un toutou benchmark de 284 1566 ce qui
le positionne exactement entre le galaxy
note 9 et le pot find x autant dire
qu'avec ce stade rigaud 845 ça carbure
sa tartine ça marche très bien en termes
de fluidité on joue on a pu déjà sur les
choses que c'est vraiment fluide ça
réagisse à la kpa ce n'est pas du tout
par contre un smartphone dédié gaming
pour moi c'est vraiment un smartphone
assez tout terrain mais qui est vraiment
dédié multimédia ça y est il y en a qui
trouvé qu'une shoot l'autonomie est
excellente sur smartphone vous avez deux
batteries 3300 millions père heures avec
de la recharge sans fil sinon vous
rechargez en usb type c on est sur une
journée sans problème alors vous pouvez
faire un peu plus ça dépend bien
évidemment comme d'habitude de votre
utilisation à l'autonomie c'est un peu
compliqué à donner exactement ça dépend
de vos habitudes ça dépend de ce que
vous allez faire avec
néanmoins pour moi vous aurez absolument
aucun problème sur une journée d' usage
franchement ça lui tiens moi ça les a
tenues font tourner sur un android 9
paille c'est cool ça marche bien pour
moi la vraie force de ce smartphone avec
le multimédia
c'est ici son appareil photo vous avez à
l'arrière un appareil motion eye 19
millions de pixels avec une ouverture de
f 2.0
c'est l'objectif en 25 mm vous avez un
autofocus hybride vous avez une
stabilisation sur cinq axes
vous avez du super slow motion en 960
images par seconde en full hd
vous pouvez filmer chant 4k hdr alors
ici je vous ferai pas la démo de la 4k
hdr parce que mes vidéos sont publiés en
1080p raconte croyez moi ça marche très
très bien le résultat est vraiment cool
avant vous avez une caméra de 13
mégapixels avec un objectif grand-angle
de 23 mm je vais vous montrer quelques
photos que j'ai fait et je vous
montrerai de la vidéo et vous allez voir
le rendu est juste top
là aussi ça marche bien rendu vraiment
bien reconnaissance de mon visage vous
le voyez pas vous mais moi je vois un
carré qui se battent au niveau de ma
tête il faut dire que sony maîtrise
vraiment la partie photo vidéo
connaissent essonniens ils ont des
boîtiers qui sont extraordinaires mais
là on parle carrément de réflexe même
soin des plus petits appareils photos ça
marche vraiment bien d'un point de vue
logiciel c'est complètement optimisé
d'un point de vue matériel ça marche
vraiment bien les capteurs sont enfin
c'est vraiment un appareil qui est top
et c'est pour ça que je vous dis que ce
smartphone est aussi un appareil photo
hyper complet au niveau de la photo il
ya énormément de possibilités et
malheureusement il faudrait une vidéo de
trois jours pour tout pouvoir les
énumérer ne serait-ce qu'au niveau des
modes édition de celle ci google dance
effet bloqué pour avoir votre flou
d'arrière-plan ralenti réalité augmentée
panoramique photo avec son effet créatif
il ya beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de
choses ça n'apparaît qui est vraiment
extrêmement complexe pour moi on est
tout simplement sur les photos qui sont
vraiment magnifiques même si je prends
des trucs pas terrible la voyez on est
carrément sur une partie de ma bécane
c'est dégueulasse mais par contre on a
vraiment le point de détail de partout
green fait plus le petit problème ça
touche latérale
ça c'est vraiment vraiment top voyez au
niveau de la pluie là c'est juste ou le
détail mais ce que je fais ou met dedans
alors plus je vais jouer je vais
ramasser un pixel ça va être moins
précis moins net mais lorsque vous la
regardez comme ça c'est vraiment
vraiment hyper hyper hyper bhl fond il
est une vraie belle réussite là dessus
sur l'appareil photo de sony
c'est beau qui marche bien par contre
effectivement il ya une partie ici qu'il
n'a pas réussi à comprendre et à
détourer c'est le brave donald qui vous
passent ses amitiés et là il a
franchement il a eu du mal ça c'est un
petit peu un pan de regret après ce qui
est cool c'est que vous pouvez modifier
les faits évoqués ici en post prod vous
pouvez en être un peu plus en être un
peu moins
c'est assez marrant voilà ça c'est cool
c'est une petite option logicielle mais
ça marche bien ça ne s'arrête pas là
vous avez du bluetooth 5.0 du nfc pour
les paiements dématérialisés
kyle à une certification ip68 donc il
est complètement étanche c'est une fois
il rencontre de l'eau ça devrait plutôt
pas mal se passer en plus vous avez un
autre hic et pas mal c'est que vous avez
un générateur en trois dimensions ça je
voulais démontrer déjà sur le xperia
2 lorsque j'étais au mwc à barcelone
vous allez pouvoir scanner le visage de
quelqu'un qui vous fait un accroc un
scan en trois dimensions vont envoyer
sur une imprimante 3d salle un prix
c'est cool ça marche bien ça sert tout
qui se développe aussi en fin d'année on
l'a vu sur le mail d'un pro on l'a vu
sur le rx 17 pro2 au pot c'est marrant
c'est un petit gadget mais c'est vrai
que bon comment voir quelle imprimante
3d se démocratise c'est bien q mais pour
avoir d avatar en 3d que ce soit sur
facebook ou autre ça aussi c'est plutôt
cool
ce smartphone ce qu'il faut vraiment
retenir dessus c'est vraiment que c'est
un appareil qui est complètement dédié
est optimisé pour le multimédia deux
points vraiment vraiment vraiment fort
au risque de nous répéter c'est son
écran bravia oled qui est magnifique
deuxième point extrêmement fort c'est
l'appareil photo l'appareil à l'arrière
l'appareil à l'avant c'est juste toth ça
marche super bien premier point un peu
négatif c'est l'emplacement du capteur
ici parce que effectivement je vous dis
on va flirter avec les caméras ça pour
moi c'est pas terrible deuxième point
que je regrette c'est le side saison va
très facilement le déclencher lorsque
vous allez utiliser dans plein de cas de
figure ça voilà pour moi c'est un
progrès parce que je trouve ça s'est
vraiment bien le fait de se dire que sur
une touche latérale ce soit à droite ou
à gauche vous allait déclencher vos
raccourcis son pari d'aller vraiment
vite tout ça optimisée grâce à de
l'intelligence artificielle
certains avouent qu'elles peuvent
paramétrer je trouve ça bien malgré tout
c'est hyper sensible ça vient aussi du
fait que l'écran est incurvé
du coup vous êtes tout le temps sur
votre scène ça vous ouvre tout le temps
ça bon peut-être qu'il ya un coup à
prendre très probablement j'imagine
qu'effectivement il ya il ya une façon
de prendre son smartphone à force on s'y
habitue y ait pas de souci mais voilà ça
c'est un petit peu un peu le point de
regret il aurait fallu peut-être dans
une seule zone pas tous les côtés on
sait que si on se met dessus ça marche
peut-être aurait-il fallu un bouton
dédié peut-être bouton dédié puisque je
vous en parle je voulais pas montrer
vous avez un bouton dédié ici qui vous
servira pour prendre des photos
extrêmement rapidement vous ouvrez
l'appareil photo vous appuyez dessus
claque ça fait une photo c'est pratique
ça marche bien pour résumer pour moi on
est sur un produit qui est hyper
puissant qui ait vraiment complètement
optimisé d'un point de vue logiciel
il ya vraiment tout ce qu'il faut à
l'intérieur souvenir vraiment bien bossé
pour que votre bécane elle tourne bien
tout le temps elle soit vraiment top
c'est vraiment un appareil pour le
divertissement youtube netflix
tout ce que vous voulez c'est top pour
l'audio c'est top
il est rapide il est beau il tombe bien
il est pratique bref je les aime
beaucoup
or quelques petites améliorations à
faire mais on n'est pas loin de la
perfection
après ça reste toujours une question de
goût et ça les goûts et les couleurs
vous savez on peut pas en discuter dites
moi vous ce que vous en pensez de ce
xperia z32 sony modèle de cette fin
d'année
est ce que vous le trouvez cool on a eu
le exode en début d'année jeu facile si
vous l'avez eue si vous l'avez acheté
est ce que vous aimez les produits de
chez sony puis est ce que vous trouvez
sur tout c'est pas le plus important est
ce que vous trouvez que sony va vraiment
dans le bon sens avec des modèles comme
ça parce que tarif de 799 euros voire un
peu moins cher
c'est vraiment un excellent smartphone
et quand on voit ce qui se fait à la
concurrence à qualité équivalente
franchement il son peuple alors après
point de regret qu'on pouvait avoir
aussi c'est se dire pourquoi est ce
qu'on a ici un seul capteur photo
pourquoi il y en a pas un deuxième qui
vient vraiment travailler pour avoir un
vrai bel effet bloquer complètement
matériels et logiciels
dites moi ce que vous en pensez en bas
en commentaire on en parle plus on me
suit vraiment l'habitude sony de très
très près parce que j'aime beaucoup
cette marque
je trouve qu'ils font un excellent
boulot ils savent se remettre en
question il leur faut un petit peu de
temps mais savent le faire et les
produits sont cool
dites moi tout ce que vous en pensez en
bas en commentaire l'invitent à les
consulter ma playlist sur les
smartphones pour découvrir tous les
smartphones du moment
et puis aller voir d'autres vidéos parce
que franchement il ya plein de choses
très intéressantes et plein de tests à
venir voilà soigner ça je vous embrasse
nous à très bientôt ciao